eduardo galeano un escritor uruguayo
decía culto no es aquel que leen más
libros
culto es aquel que es capaz de escuchar
al otro
culto tiene que ver con nosotros con la
capacidad que tenemos de expresarnos y
de relacionarnos con nuestro entorno
por lo tanto
cultos somos todos
no hay incultos y otros cultos porque
todos nos relacionamos y tiene que ver
con la capacidad no solamente de
escuchar sino de ver de mirar de
mirarnos
en los otros y de mirarnos con los otros
[Música]
laura existe que decía
la cultura no es una actividad del
tiempo libre sino es lo que nos hace
libres todo el tiempo
y aquí quiero mencionar que a veces se
confunde la cultura con mero
esparcimiento con solamente divertirnos
con event it is
y la verdad es que
la cultura así es la primera en el
discurso pero es la última en el
presupuesto
a veces piensan total si lo único que
hacen son eventos
pero la cultura tiene que ver con algo
mucho más profundo tiene que ver con el
ser humano tiene que ver con cada uno de
nosotros tiene que ver con nuestra
identidad tiene que ver como dice jorge
melguizo
con la certeza de que es una inversión
estructural y potenciar potenciar y
potenciar lo que se hace
entonces todo de alguna manera estamos
involucrados en esta capacidad de
potenciar
de mirarnos en los otros de mirar de
escuchar a los otros y de construir
ciudadanía y construir una sociedad
la cultura sin duda debe ser el eje para
el desarrollo
por supuesto tiene que ver en la parte
más humana y en la parte del desarrollo
humano y social
se imaginan ustedes
qué sería de nosotros
sin los murales de diego rivera sin la
obra de frida de orozco decir queirós
de sal de picasso
los textos la literatura de octavio paz
o de garcía márquez o de neruda o de
hemingway
se imaginan ustedes que sería si la
música que bajan de spotify
o las películas que vemos en el cine o
en netflix o en alguna otra plataforma
que sería de nuestra vida sin todo tipo
de expresiones porque finalmente las
expresiones artísticas reflejan
la vida cotidiana y son un espejo de
nuestra sociedad
el primer acercamiento que tenemos con
la cultura tiene es desde que estamos en
el vientre y escuchamos la voz de
nuestra madre
que nos habla
y cuando nacemos
las primeras palabras que nos dicen por
qué porque es el primer acercamiento con
el lenguaje
si nos cuentan
si nos cantan
los arroyos
el contarle a un niño desde que está en
el vientre y por supuesto cuando acaba
de nacer no saben lo potencial y lo
importante que es
va fortaleciendo ese lazo
con la madre con el padre con el entorno
y forman seres humanos más seguros más
confiables y luego conforme vamos
creciendo imagínense que traemos aquí
una mochila y vamos cargando y vamos
depositando ahí las creencias que
venimos heredando de nuestros ancestros
las costumbres las tradiciones la forma
de hablar
obviamente lo que comemos también lo
venimos heredando y a lo largo del
tiempo vamos construyendo nuestra
identidad o múltiples identidades
con eso que nos van forjando pero
también con lo que vamos aprendiendo
y por supuesto con lo que vamos
eligiendo
y eso
llegó un momento en que nosotros
decidimos quiénes somos
como nos reconocemos como queremos
comunicarnos con el mundo y por supuesto
quienes queremos ser
por eso es tan importante el respeto la
tolerancia y el reconocimiento a la
diversidad cultural
a la pluralidad cultural
y por eso hay que reconocer y valorar
aquel que dice huerto aquí en el norte
lo que dice book y en la otra parte del
norte
aquel que come carne asada como aquí
o qué
disfruta de los tamales del pollo que se
hace en yucatán
cada quien va forjando su identidad
y eso nos va nutriendo y nos va dando
características culturales por eso es
tan importante reconocer el que la
cultura tiene que ver con el desarrollo
humano y el desarrollo de una sociedad
de un entorno de una comunidad y la
cultura también forma parte del
desarrollo económico y a veces eso no lo
pensamos y eso sería muy importante
recordarles a todos los administradores
en los diferentes niveles de gobierno
saben ustedes que la cultura aporta el
2.9 por ciento del producto interno
bruto a nivel nacional
las industrias culturales y creativas
los artistas
las tecnologías
un videojuego
atrás hay un diseñador y hay un creativo
las veces que vamos al cine o que
venimos al centro cultural o visitamos
un museo
los festivales como el festival
internacional de la raza que es perdón
bueno de la raza y el festival
internacional tamaulipas que se hacía
aquí en en todo el estado aporta una
gran cantidad y una derrama económica
tan importante
porque porque no solamente se le da
empleo a los artistas ya los creadores
pero también a los técnicos a los
iluminadores al sonido a las pantallas
como los eventos por supuesto como el
día de hoy la gente para salir a un
evento ya por lo menos consumir también
gasolina y luego después si tú te vas a
comer unos tacos por lo menos hay una
gran derrama económica que se impulsa a
través de la cultura y a veces esa no la
tomamos en cuenta
a todos los empresarios hay que seguir
invirtiendo por supuesto también en la
cultura y considerar la cultura como un
eje del desarrollo económico de la
comunidad y por supuesto por supuesto
que la cultura contribuye a mejores o
mejores entornos para la paz y la
esperanza a la cuestión a esa llamada a
la reconstitución del tejido social
y la cultura sin duda como lo dice jorge
melguizo contribuye a tener mejores
escenarios para la paz
a veces unos creen y lo acabamos de ver
ahorita con la ley de seguridad interior
que teniendo a militar esos policías en
las calles vamos a poder contribuir a
tener mejores entornos libres de
violencia y no como dice jorge melguizo
lo contrario a la inseguridad no es la
seguridad es la convivencia
la posibilidad de construir con el otro
de vernos con el otro y aquí quiero
platicarles de algunos ejemplos donde
precisamente la convivencia ha permitido
y construir mejores escenarios para la
paz podemos ver por ejemplo los
colectivos culturales comunitarios en
tamaulipas que son jóvenes
aprendieron con diferentes técnicas y
herramientas a intervenir espacios
públicos con actividades artísticas y
culturales para poder generar mejores
condiciones de vida para los habitantes
de ese espacio cada vez vemos que se
construyen nuevos parques que se
construyen nuevas plazas pero esos son
espacios vacíos y no les damos vida sino
los intervenimos y si los jóvenes de
manera especial no participan en el
desarrollo y en la construcción de una
comunidad
otro ejemplo podemos ver aquí en el
colectivo comunitario de radio que ese
justo se construyó aquí en nuevo laredo
se formó nuevo laredo que es un
colectivo donde la radio era la
herramienta o la oportunidad de poder
expresarse pero donde conformó a jóvenes
de un sector allá por la secundaria 47
principalmente y ahora en un cebetis
donde encontraron
en ese núcleo que es el colectivo
comunitario de radio la oportunidad de
hacer una familia de construir lazos de
poder comunicar
otro ejemplo él
las agrupaciones musicales comunitarias
que hay bandas orquestas ensambles no
solamente en tamaulipas sino en
muchísimos lados del país esta es un
programa que se inició en venezuela con
las agrupaciones comunitarias y las
grandes orquestas
para que no para formar grandes músicos
esa no es la intención sino para
utilizar un violín utilizar una trompeta
utilizar un instrumento para que los
niños primero tuvieran un sentido de
pertenencia a un grupo se conformarán
aprendieran a trabajar en lo colectivo
aprendieran a trabajar con los demás y
entendieran que con la música podían
expresarse y podían construir mucho más
allá quiero comentarles un ejemplo muy
brevemente esta fotografía de aquí abajo
es de la orquesta sinfónica comunitaria
de tampico
cuando se forma la orquesta comunitaria
hace algunos años
allá en una comunidad del barrio él
tancol
de repente en la escuela que albergaba
la orquesta decía nosotros ya no podemos
tenerlos aquí porque no tenemos donde
resguardar los instrumentos
y los niños con los papás dijeron si el
problema es donde resguardar los
instrumentos nosotros con nuestras manos
y nuestras actividades construimos una
bodega
entonces como una orquesta que se dedica
a hacer música fue construyendo más allá
la capacidad de organización de las
familias de los padres de los maestros
de los niños o sea como la cultura
permitió establecer lazos formar redes y
tejer otras condiciones
la foto del medio ustedes pueden ver
algunos niños ahí jugando y están
jugando a hacer teatro y este es un
ejemplo del colectivo comunitario de
teatro en barra del tordo allá que es
una comunidad del municipio de aldama
tamaulipas en la costa de tamaulipas del
golfo
y en una ocasión un niño
que se llama lucas que en ese entonces
tenía como cinco años dijo yo quiero
hacer teatro
y entonces se logró la oportunidad de
involucrar a una compañía de teatro de
tampico para que fueran constantemente a
trabajar con los niños de barra del
tordo y formar un colectivo comunitario
de teatro
lo más importante para mí que tuve la
oportunidad de conocer estos niños es
que si les preguntabas qué representa
para ti hacer teatro decían ser feliz
ser felices la cultura lo que permite es
construir alternativas para la felicidad
lucas como la mayor parte de estos niños
ya andarán por el quinto año y el
compromiso es que por lo menos este
colectivo comunitario de teatro
acompañado con la compañía de teatro de
tampico los acompañan hasta que salgan
de la primaria pero algo mucho más
importante que hacer teatro les permitió
que convivir con su familia convivir con
los maestros convivir entre ellos y
aprender que si no se dan la mano unos a
otros no podían trabajar como una
comunidad aprendieron a ser ciudadanos
porque ciudadano no es solamente que te
den el papelito ciudadano es construir
con la comunidad
y algo muy reciente en estos días es
este mural
en el parque de silao aquí de la colonia
las torres en este momento
están niños de la colonia las torres
jóvenes de las colonias aledañas
trabajando con un artista que se llama
alfredo libre gutiérrez
y están haciendo un mural y están
haciendo una pinta de un mural en una
barda de una maquiladora que queda justo
frente al parque silao si una algo
importante es lo que podemos ver
plasmado después en ese muro pero lo más
importante es que esos niños están
aprendiendo aquí a través de trabajar y
de participar en una actividad artística
a respetar su entorno están re valorando
la identidad del barrio la identidad lo
que los hace sentirse orgullosos de
vivir en nuevo laredo de ser quienes son
esto es lo que construye a la cultura
esto es lo que nos permite sin duda
construir mejores escenarios para la paz
y la esperanza y así yo les puedo
platicar muchísimas otras historias la
historia por ejemplo de un taller de
fotografía que se dio en
se llama brechas allá en unos caminos
que dan
por el rumbo de reynosa por el rumbo de
matamoros y así imaginan en las brechas
qué es lo que hay por ahí y qué es lo
que cruza por ahí y si un fotógrafo
diego huerta llegó impartió unos
talleres de fotografía donde los niños
aprendieran
no solamente a tomar fotos sino a
retratar y a contar historias a través
de una cámara sobre su entorno sobre
cómo viven sobre cómo son
sobre su familia sobre su colonia sobre
su casa
y en la clausura de ese taller contaba
diego huerta que se le acercó un señor y
decía usted es el maestro si yo soy el
maestro quiero felicitarlo
porque yo veo lo entusiasmada que está
mi hija con este taller y la verdad no
quiero
que mi hija se dedique a lo que yo me
dedico
se levanta la camisa y ya se imaginan
qué fue lo que enseño cuando el papá
reconoce que ese taller que utilizando
una cámara que permitiéndole expresar a
su hija le iba a cambiar la vida
ahí es donde decimos bendita cultura y
el poder que tiene de poder llegar
al otro de poder comunicar de poder
expresar por eso todos
tenemos la capacidad de hacer algo por
los demás a través de lo que somos la
cultura tiene que ver con nuestra
identidad con quiénes somos con cómo nos
comportamos como construimos estos
escenarios alrededor de nosotros
por eso la cultura es una tarea no
solamente del gobierno no importa si es
federal estatal o municipal
invertir en cultura es invertir en el
ser humano invertir en cultura es
invertir en el otro invertir en cultura
es invertir en la parte más sublime más
poética
qué tiene que ver con la parte del
corazón de los sentimientos de la
imaginación y de la capacidad como decía
eduardo galiano de escuchar invertir en
cultura es algo que deberíamos de estar
haciendo todos desde nuestra propia
trinchera
por eso es tan importante la labor que
hacen los creadores los artistas los
promotores culturales por eso hay que
reconocer
a las ciudades que invierten en este
tipo de infraestructura en espacios
culturales en centros culturales no
importa si son de esta magnitud o si es
un centro cultural comunitario en una
colonia en un ejido por qué porque están
permitiendo el desarrollo de alguien de
una comunidad por eso a la cultura no
hay que ningunear la no hay que seguir
viendo a la cultura como un mero adorno
sino como la oportunidad de construir
procesos
para el desarrollo sino la oportunidad
de construirnos a nosotros mismos de
reflexionar sobre quiénes somos
repito imagínense ustedes que sería de
la vida que sería de nosotros sin poder
escuchar nuestra canción favorita sin
poder ver una película sin poder llorar
cuando admiramos por ejemplo
la forma del agua de guillermo del toro
o cuando o atacarnos de la risa a lo
mejor con una película de tinta o de
cantinflas
hay que respetar los gustos y hay que
respetar
a lo que cada uno quiere para su
comunidad y por eso es tan importante
construir desde la cultura yo solamente
los quiero dejar con esto que escribió
fernando vicario la cultura puede ser la
llave que nos ayude así a abrir los
candados que les cierran las puertas a
la diversidad o la que nos abra las
puertas de la creatividad que nos ayude
a entrar sin recelos y rancios enganches
a disfrutar del pasado que nos abra la
puerta que nos impedía encontrarnos con
el otro que permita salir sin miedo a
quien estaba atrapado en el interior de
ese oscuro túnel que es la xenofobia o
la incomprensión gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]